80 des films on vous remercie d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
vous êtes également l'auteur de
l'ouvragé aux politiques de l'algérie
aux éditions bibliomonde
abdelaziz bouteflika sera inhumé dans la
matinée à une cérémonie a minima pas de
funérailles nationales
on sait que l'annoncé du décès de
l'ancien dirigeant a été reçu à une
discrétion par le pays parfois même avec
embarras c'est qu'aujourd'hui la rancune
persiste contre l'ancien président
algérien
bonjour écoutez plutôt que de parler de
rancune je pense que c'est l'heure du
bilan et ce bilan forcément pour comme
pour tous les responsables politiques
est
contrasté et dans le cas de bouter
défense c'est un bilan mitigé parce
qu'il laisse derrière lui un un pays
littéralement ruiné et un tas de cendres
et c'est assez paradoxal avec ce qu'il a
incarné au début de sa vie politique
après l'indépendance de l'algérie et le
népotisme le niveau de corruption
l'arbitraire seront portés à son crédit
malheureusement et son bilan sera plutôt
à regarder dans la colonne du passif
mettons que dans celui des actifs parce
que l'algérie aujourd'hui est à la
croisée des chemins elle est au bord une
situation financière dramatique qui
pourrait conduire à prendre des mesures
très compliqué très difficile pour les
algériens eux-mêmes vous l'avez dit il
était à ses débuts une incarnation
peut-être du nationalisme algérien et
puis au fur et à mesure des années voilà
il a été contesté chasser du pouvoir
donc en 2019 beaucoup regrettent
beaucoup d'algériens regrette qu'il
n'ait pas été jugé avant sa mort
oui la seule chose que l'on peut
maintenant faire ses éventuels mans
dresser le bilan
jugé le la relaxe ou qui a été la sienne
en vingt ans de pouvoir c'est pas un
assez terrible pour un homme qui dès
2013 ne pouvait plus représenté son pays
ni
assumer les devoirs de sa charge
puisqu'il a fait un avc en 2013 et donc
je crois que c'est maintenant vers cela
qu'il faut se tourner parce que lille va
y avoir une énorme frustration et d'une
certaine manière faire le bilan des
années bouteflika s'est également
rejoindre les revendications de théâtre
est rappelé que c'est tout un système
qui s'est confondue avec l'histoire avec
la trajectoire d'un homme et que c'est
ça aujourd'hui qu'il faut tenter de
dépasser de transcender pour favoriser
une transition politique en douceur et
non pas dans l'avion une transition
politique en douceur qui doit être mené
par abdelmagid tebboune l'actuel
président algérien le chantier est
colossal selon vous
oui les normes et je ne sais pas je
m'interroge je suis très sceptique sur
les capacités du président actuel du
présente paul pas pouvoir assumer cela
est-ce qu'il en a la volonté
est ce qu'il y ait un véritable projet
politique qui se construirait sur un
socle de valeurs communes qui seraient
largement partagé par les algériens
j'en suis pas sûr du tout aujourd'hui on
n'a plus la sensation d'un homme du
président de beaune qui est lui assez
absent il a été absent pendant quatre 70
jours pour des raisons médicales
donc qu'est-ce qu'il a toutes les
capacités physiques aujourd'hui pour
assumer les devoirs de sa charge est ce
qu'il à l'envi est-ce qu'il a un
véritable projet toutes ces questions la
demeure pour le moment sans réponse mais
il faudra que il puisse très rapidement
je crois qu'il n'aura pas d'effets n'a
pas d'état de grâce et qui va devoir
très rapidement donner une orientation
claire afin que les algériens se
rassemble
dernière question voilà les algériens
qui enterre donc dans la matinée en asie
sa beauté flicka mais finalement que
reste-t-il aujourd'hui de l'héritage de
l'ancien chef de l'état
je écouter
répondre à cette question c'est un peu
ce livre est soi même et
je je je pense évidemment qu'il faudra
faire un bilan contrasté je dirais que
toute la première partie de son premier
mandat au tout début des années 2000 a
été très favorable à l'algérie il a fait
cesser les combats fratricides
il a mis un point final à la guerre des
années 90 entre l'armée et les
islamistes
il a contribué à sortir l'algérie en
diplomate chevronné qu'il était assortie
en algérie de son isolement il a
beaucoup voyagé et il a également ramené
l'algérie dans le concert des nations
notamment avec son homologue sud
africain thabo m'beki sûr à propos du
nepad et du nouveau plan de
développement de l'afrique donc tout
cela est indéniablement apporté à son
crédit et puis il ya la dimension plus
haut le népotisme le niveau de
corruption l'émergence d'une véritable
oligarchie des affaires qui a bâti des
fortunes considérables et qui sera sans
doute
par l'histoire orthez à son débit merci
beaucoup en tout cas quand des radars
qui est d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes maître de
conférences à sciences po directeur de
recherche à l'ubs se et auteur de
l'ouvragé aux politiques de l'algérie
aux éditions habib sy au monde